>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Regan Smith: So panel
two is called the Rulemaking
Process-Evidentiary
and Procedural Issues.
So if this is what you're here
for, you're in the right place.
I'd like to start for us
briefly introducing ourselves.
First from the Copyright
Office, I'm Regan Smith,
Associate General Counsel.
>> Kevin Amer: Kevin Amer,
Senior Counsel for Policy
and International Affairs.
>> Andrew Moore: Andrew
Moore, Ringer Fellow.
>> Jason Sloan: Jason Sloan,
I'm an Attorney Adviser
in the General Counsel's Office.
>> Regan Smith: And of the parties
we'd like to introduce, you know,
your names and organization
you represent.
>> Krista L. Cox: Krista Cox, the
Association of Research Libraries.
>> Peter Decherney: Peter Decherney
from the University of Pennsylvania.
>> Robyn Greene: Robyn Greene,
from New America's Open
Technology Institute.
>> Chris Mohr: Chris Mohr, SIAA.
>> Matt Williams: Matt Williams from
the MSK law firm for the Association
of American Publishers, the Motion
Picture Association of America,
and Recording Industry
Association of America.
>> Rebecca Tushnet: Rebecca
Tushnet, the Organization
for Transformative Works.
>> Bruce H. Turnbull:
Bruce Turnbull,
representing the DVD
Copy Control Association
and the Advance Access Content
System Licensing Administrator, LLC.
>> Raza Panjwani: Raza
Panjwani, Public Knowledge.
>> Regan Smith: Great.
So this panel is to explore
the general operation
of the triennial rulemaking process.
I see that many of the panelists
are participants in the process.
And so, they're probably aware
that last October concluded
the sixth process
where the Office received
44 petitions.
We grouped this into 27
categories of exemptions.
The Register recommended
and the Librarian adopted
the granting of 22.
But through that process, the Office
received nearly 40,000 written
comments and we understand that
the comments written in support
of this study, you know,
for many participants,
it was seen as taking a lot of time
and perhaps a disproportionate
amount of time.
The comments and testimony
that we received during the last
session reflected considerable
efforts from individual
participants,
nonprofit organizations, law firms,
legal clinics and industry members.
And we're interested in
hearing your thoughts
about the procedural aspects
of the rulemaking as well
as the evidentiary
standards that are applied.
And keep in mind, some of you
will also be on panel three.
But that topic is whether or
not there should be some sort
of presumptive renewal or
streamlining for renewals
of exemptions that are granted.
So we're going to try to
respect that that's the topic
of the next panel, as
opposed to this panel.
So I think to start out, I'll
just ask a very broad question.
For those that have
participated in the process,
how do you find it's
working for you?
And in the answers, please
just tip your placards
up if you wish to speak.
And if you could please try to
keep your response to maybe two
to three minutes, we'd
appreciate it.
Thank you.
Professor Tushnet?
>> Rebecca Tushnet: So not so well.
So we dedicated really
probably 500 to 600 hours,
if I'd look at my time,
which I don't keep
with the same regularity
you would at a law firm,
and several other people,
other lawyers volunteering
for my organization also
dedicated significant time as well
as conversations with technical
people and other people and some
of our members who take
advantage of the exemption.
So it was a big deal.
And there are significant
problems with the requirements
that the Office currently imposes.
I think the Cyberlaw Clinic's
comments go into great detail,
and I'm largely in agreement.
So I won't run through there.
I would say one specific issue in
particular that doesn't work well.
So for three rounds, we
have made the argument
that the Copyright Office
should consider actual knowledge
and behavior among potential
users of an exemption
when interpreting whether there
are alternatives to circumvention.
That is, it should consider
whether these alternatives are
in fact known and used.
And frankly, it's quite frustrating
that the Copyright Office has
not even addressed this argument,
much less given a reason why
it has rejected this argument,
which we could actually
then talk about.
It's also contrary to the
due process principles
and the notice-and-comment
practice of rulemaking.
And, you know, I'd just
like to hear something
from the Copyright
Office about that.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Mr. Turnbull?
>> Bruce H. Turnbull: My clients
have participated, DVD CCA,
in all of the prior rulemakings,
and AACS in the last couple
and I would say in general, we
actually find that it works well.
I think the basic approach
is correct that there--
that those who seek the exemption
have the information that's
necessary to bring forward and
that's how it has been put forward.
I think the-- and the notion
that the basic presumption is
that the prohibitions are to stand
unless there is evidence brought
forward sufficient to
demonstrate the need
for the exemption is
the correct approach.
I think that there are
details about how many rounds
of submissions there are,
whether the initial round
in the last rulemaking was necessary
or additionally burdensome.
I think from the responding
parties' point of view,
we wound up with one response--
you know, one opportunity,
whereas other participants,
the proponents had multiple.
And so, again, in the details,
I think there are places
that could be improved.
But as an overall matter, I
think we find that it works well.
>> Regan Smith: If I could ask if
you could turn off your microphone
when you're done speaking, that will
just help prevent feedback noise.
And also, a follow-up
to Mr. Turnbull,
did you feel as participating
in the second cycle of comments
and there not being a
fourth that, you know,
there was something you had
left unsaid or did you feel
that you had the opportunity
to express your viewpoint
on all issues?
>> Bruce H. Turnbull: Well,
the concern largely was that--
I mean, I understand the
inclination of proponents
to bring forward evidence
or information
in response to what was submitted.
But we really-- other
than through the hearings,
which was an imperfect
way of doing it,
partly because of the time
limitations and the questions
and that sort of thing, there were
things in the responding round
from the proponents that
one would have liked
to have had an opportunity
to respond to.
I mean, there are different
ways that that could be handled.
I mean, the Copyright Office could
be more vigilant in saying no
to submissions of new evidence
or giving another round
or, you know, other ways.
But I would say that there were,
particularly in this last
proceeding, there were times
when we would have responded
if we had the opportunity.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Thank you.
Mr. Panjwani?
>> Raza Panjwani: There are a
number of aspects of the proceeding
that we've been involved in that
we've highlighted as problematic.
In fact, we've filed general
comments at the outset
of the last triennial process to
highlight some of the issues we had,
beginning with the identification of
classes of works under section 102
for the exemption process,
the standard of identifying
non-infringing uses
as well as adverse effects.
I particularly want to focus on
the first two, in part, because,
as Professor Tushnet mentioned,
the Cyberlaw Clinic's comments
on the adverse effects I think
were very appropriate and sort
of addressed that very thoroughly.
Currently, the approach
to identifying classes
of works results in-- as
alluded to in the prior panel,
some distinctions that
don't quite make sense.
So, for example, the difference
between tablets and phones
that involve the same
exact software,
thus bifurcating the docket and
require filings in both cases.
The differentiation between users,
educators by differentiating
the classes of users as either K
through educators or
higher education educators,
which it's unclear where these
distinctions in terms of classes
of works come from or
the differentiation
in granting an exemption
between a Blu-Ray disc
and a DVD disc as a user.
Beyond that, in terms of the burden
that we find as problematic in terms
of filing-- identifying
non-infringing uses is
that the expectation that proponents
must identify affirmative precedent
affirming a non-infringement
whereas the dearth
of precedent identifying an
infringing activity does not satisfy
the burden.
This is particularly problematic
because without an exemption,
a party cannot engage
in the activity,
which means that there is a lack
of an opportunity for case law
to develop in that space.
In fact, I would characterize the
lack of an exemption in some areas
as effectively denying courts of
jurisdiction to define the contours
of infringement in
that particular area.
If you cannot circumvent for
purposes of engaging in an activity,
there's no way of defining one way
or another whether that's actually
infringing in a court's eyes,
if there is no case
law on that point.
I have other areas, but
I'm going to stop there.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
I think you've raised a
lot of issues and some
of those we'll begin
to drill deeper into.
But I do want to give
everyone an opportunity
to speak a little bit at opening.
And I think one of the things to
consider maybe as we continue going
around is to what extent
are some of these issues
that you're raising sort
of dictated by the statute,
which requires a finding
that an activity is likely
to be non-infringing.
So Ms. Cox?
>> Krista L. Cox: So the Association
of Research Libraries
has participated
in the rulemaking process as part
of the Library Copyright Alliance.
And it-- the process is just--
it takes an extraordinary amount
of time, as Professor
Tushnet mentioned, you know,
took like 500 to 600 hours.
We're very lucky to have the
assistance of some of the clinics
that we've worked with and joined
in some of their filings because,
otherwise, it really does take
an extraordinary amount of time
and resources where you have
to assemble the evidence,
you have to submit the
proposal, including the text.
You have to basically write a brief
on why your use is non-infringing
and you have to then respond to
any opposition to those proposals,
prepare a written reply,
participate in the hearings
and then do the follow-up questions.
And you know, this whole
process can take a year or more,
which is just an extraordinary
amount of time for something
that is proposed by
public interest groups
that often don't have the time
and resources to invest in this.
And this is why we are very
grateful to the clinics.
Just on Raza's point
about that the lack
of exemption denies courts
these opportunities, you know,
it really does make putting together
this evidence very, very difficult.
It makes writing these briefs on
why it's a non-infringing use--
it can make it-- make
it more difficult.
And as Mr. Turnbull said, you
know, he believes that those
who want the exemptions
have the opportunity
and the information necessary.
And I would disagree
just to the extent
that this process really
provides an asymmetry of interest
where these corporations
are usually the ones
that are proposing these
exemptions whereas it is
like these public interest groups
that don't have these
resources needed to walk
through this very complicated
and burdensome
and very formalistic system.
>> Regan Smith: Mr. Mohr?
>> Chris Mohr: A couple of--
just I guess a couple
of preliminary points.
The first thing is I think there's--
I want to be clear in
distinguishing between, let's say,
problems with the statute and
problems with the rulemaking.
There are-- from our mind-- in
our mind, there are areas where,
in fact overall, the statute
is working quite well.
And I think in the comments from
AAP and the MPAA and also in ours,
we've tried to give some examples
of how new business models
have been encouraged.
This was designed to be a failsafe.
And it was designed to
operate in a certain way.
And I think you hit on that.
And that is specifically
with respect to the statute,
that the statute has to be a
source of causation of the harm.
It can't be alternative
distribution models.
It can't be the fact that
something is inconvenient.
It has to be the statute that
is causing the adverse effect.
And I think, to the extent that the
rulemaking has gone off the rails a
bit, it might be useful to examine
how closely the library is hewn
to that particular standard.
>> Regan Smith: Can you elaborate,
if you think that the
rulemaking has gone away
from the standards set
out in the statute?
>> Chris Mohr: Well,
initially, I mean it--
it's, you know-- it's changed.
The library has changed
its position.
I mean the initial-- the initial
rulemaking, the very first one,
there was a fairly
large fight over whether
or not an exemption
should issue to a class
of users or to a class of works.
And the initial rulemaking tried
to stay pretty close to that line.
And I think later, it got much
more into the class of user
and then it got a lot fuzzier.
I think there are places where there
are-- there may be other statutes,
for example, that prohibit a
particular course of conduct.
And so, if assuming
both statutes are valid,
assuming both statutes
prescribed the same conduct,
the section 1201 can't
be prescribed as a cause.
It's a way the proceeding
is being used
of validating some other policy
goal that they would like to have
but has nothing to
do with copyright.
In that particular instance,
I'm not sure that issuance
of an exemption is appropriate.
In other words, tie
goes to no exemption.
That's-- those are the
sorts of things I mean
by statutory causation, if you like.
>> Regan Smith: Mr. Williams.
>> Matt Williams: Thank you.
Thank you.
I like to reiterate first what--
what Mr. Turnbull said in
the sense that, you know,
the comments by their very nature
kind of contain a lot of criticism
of what the Office has done
but I think you guys also
deserve a good bit of phrase
for taking a tricky statute
and making a proceeding that's
overall worked quite well.
I think we're in kind of a-- it's
not broken, so you had to be very,
very careful trying
to fix it scenario.
Again, it's functioning
as it was intended to.
We're not always happy
with the outcomes.
We're frequently unhappy with some
of them and we've got a few things
in our comments that we
think could be improved.
One important one I think is
we would love to see a draft
of the regulatory language in
advance of it being published just
so that everyone who
participated in the hearings
at least can comment on
the drafting choices.
But some of those things are
relatively minor improvements
that we think could be made.
And overall, we think-- we think
things are working pretty well.
On Bruce's point about the
one filing versus three
from the last cycle, we also felt
that there were some
things left unsaid.
Part of that was because of the
hearing, I think, as you should,
you gave the proponents a lot of
opportunity to explain their cases.
And then as who were sitting
at the end of the table,
ended up running out
of time sometimes.
So having one more written
filing might have been helpful.
I just have a very few
brief things in response
to some of what's being said.
I think Public Knowledge
raised the issue
of why should we be distinguishing
between different types of users
and I think that's
something that grew
out of what Mr. Mohr
was talking about,
which is that we've altered the
approach somewhat and that a class
of users was not something that
was initially being looked at.
But overall, I think my
clients have come to find
that that change has been helpful.
It's not perfect and we do have some
concerns about-- about how it works.
But overall, I think we
have found it to be helpful.
And so in the previous panel,
Jonathan Band was raising
the issue of, well,
this is going to keep growing
and growing and growing
and eventually the whole building
is going to have to work on it.
But I think that is in large part
the result of the Office trying
to be accommodating to
the proponents and trying
to let them make their case and--
and expanded the approach
to allow the class
of works definition to be altered.
And so, sometimes you
have to take a little bit
of bad with a lot of good.
And so that I think is kind
of why the proceeding
has grown the way it has.
The last point I wanted to
respond to was this issue
that 1201 supposedly
inhibits the development
of normal copyright case
law or fair use case law.
I don't-- I've never
understood that argument
and I still don't understand
that argument.
I understand that there are two
different types of liability
and that in counseling a
client, you have to address both.
On other hand, if there
are the number of threats
that people claim there are of
1201 liability, there are lots
of ways to-- to pursue declaratory
relief actions without connection
to the 1201 threat and still
pursue your copyright arguments.
There are lots of fair use
cases going on out there.
I'm involved in a lot of them on
both sides, often on the defense.
There are a lot of other types of
exemptions, related cases going
on that have nothing to
do with 1201 so I just--
I don't believe that the
case law is being inhibited.
Thank you.
>> Regan Smith: OK, well, we did
open up with a broad question.
I think now we've got a
lot of issues to unpack.
So I think that I might be
hopping around a little bit
but on the question of how
to define a class of works,
it is true as others have mentioned
that in the first rulemaking,
the Office did not define a class
of works by reference to the users
but subsequently from the
second rule making on, it has.
And my question is if this were
to be taking an opposite approach
and not allow refining it by
the types of users or uses,
would this be likely to result
in perhaps less exemptions.
What effect does this have in the
rulemaking if you need to look
at sort of a wide approval in terms
of whether an activity is
likely to be non-infringing?
So Professor Decherney?
>> Peter Decherney: Yeah, thank you.
So I've been participating in the
rulemaking since 2006 when it was--
when the use and users were added
to the definition of class works.
I think it's not a question
of whether or not the--
it becomes larger or smaller as
a class but it brings the idea
of a class much more
in line with fair use
which is about use and users.
And of course, all non-infringing
uses aren't about fair use.
There are plenty of kinds of
non-infringing use which are
about exemptions like the 110,
but fair use is obviously
is really important one.
So I think it actually makes the
logic of the arguments much--
much cleaner and brings them
in the line with fair use.
We're not talking about video games
that can only be played
on obsolete technology.
But it's about use by
archivists, which is really what
that exemption was meant to be used
for going all the way
back to 2003 and 2006.
Could I add a few other
comments from the first round?
>> Regan Smith: Sure.
Go ahead.
>> Peter Decherney: So
I mean, in some ways,
the rulemaking has I think
really been effective and,
from my own perspective, many, many,
you know, thousands of educators
and students have been
able to engage
in non-infringing uses as a result.
And there are so many
changes that have helped that,
including the added
addition of use and users
and the streamlining of the process.
So I'm happy we see that
you're open to new changes.
I mean to-- just to bring up
two small issues, two issues,
not so small, one is the
emphasis that we place
on the next three years
in each rulemaking.
Often we end up debating things
that end to be vaporware,
technologies that never
materialize, licensing agreements
which are still being negotiated
even 16 years after we first heard
about them and if there's a
way to keep that to things
that are tangible and real
and that there's evidence
that they exist would be terrific.
The other is what we're going
to talk about this afternoon,
which is the renewal process.
And so, I'll put that aside.
But you know, I'd love to rethink
what de novo may mean and whether
or not we need to use
that standard at all.
But also, maybe something more
appropriate for this, you know,
part of the hearing is how
evidence is preserved and used
and then maybe reused
for the future.
>> Regan Smith: Yeah, and keeping
in mind that the next panel is going
to talk about renewals, like if
there were some type of reform
for renewals, it seems
like it might take some
of the pressure off the
participants in each
of the rulemakings going anew.
But Mr. Panjwani?
I think I might-- am
I saying that right?
OK. Panjwani.
>> Raza Panjwani: I'd also like to
just respond very briefly to some
of the points made previously.
It was already mentioned in amount
of hours that have to be put
in by proponents, ranging from
500 by a few of the clinics
to as high as, I believe, 2000
hours was the number listed
in the reply comments
by the filmmakers,
by the UC Irvine Law Clinic as
well as their Pro Bono Counsel.
I don't think a system that
relies on Pro Bono Counsel
and the availability of
clinics is sustainable.
And Mr. Williams doesn't
believe that we're going
to have necessarily
this proliferation.
But one example that came
up was consumer appliances
and the software embedded in
them are not covered by any
of the exemptions and
we're going to have
to wait two years to deal with that.
And that's going to be an
additional class that's going
to require addressing an
additional proponent work.
In terms of the specifics of the
comment periods of the process,
I will note that in my limited
experience as a litigator
in motion practice, typically
the party with the burden
of proof is allowed to file
in favor and a reply brief,
and a sur-reply brief the fourth
round is typically not given
as of right.
I would also note that
it's important to realize
that the burden, as we often
hear from the Copyright Office,
the burden is on the proponents
to the point that there is no
such thing as a default
judgment in favor of proponents.
It is possible to have
your exemption denied
without anyone actually opposing it,
as the Register recommended
the denial
of 24 the e-book reading
exemption back in 2010
without any substantive opposition.
I would also note that the
problems with the process in terms
of the accessibility of the public
in understanding what's going
on were delineated in the Cyberlaw
Clinic's comments that pointed
out that there are effectively nine
factors that the Office considers.
And you cannot find those nine
factors listed in one place.
But rather, one must parse both
the original NOI requesting classes
being identified and then the NPRM
calling for the rulemaking process.
And in combination, one
gets this multifactor test
that is highly technical
and requires all these
hours to actually meet.
>> Regan Smith: Again,
I'm just going to move
on so we can facilitate this.
Again, I think these issues
end up being a bit intertwined.
>> Raza Panjwani: Right.
>> Regan Smith: But I'm
trying to focus it--
>> Raza Panjwani: Sure.
>> Regan Smith: -- to narrow it.
I wonder if we can get
back to the question
of the definition of
the class of works.
>> Raza Panjwani: So I understand
the difficulty the Office has
in that they're asked to
define classes of works.
But exemptions must be granted
for non-infringing uses.
And then, connecting those
two perhaps leads to some
of the difficulties that we have.
I would say that there
is a middle ground though
between the atomization that
currently occurs in the defining
of classes and the
section 102 classes.
I believe that we've veered too
far in terms of where we are.
I think motion pictures for
classes of fair uses as opposed to,
you know, particular types
of formats I think is
where we start running
into sort of shallow waters
and fear of running aground.
I think software also presents some
difficulties in terms of tying it
to a particular type of device,
whereas perhaps software needs
to be treated as its
own class that is
in fact a narrower subgroup
than literary works.
So I would urge perhaps a
movement away from the level
of specificity currently in
the definition of classes.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Professor Tushnet?
>> Rebecca Tushnet: So what was
just said is exactly what I think
about the classes too, especially
since the burden placed sometimes
doesn't inform us exactly, you know,
how specific we have to be.
There's not-- and right now,
we have no reason to think
or understand why, you know, the
exemption isn't for the University
of Pennsylvania instead of for
college professors because,
you know, it's somebody
from the University
of Pennsylvania who's
coming and asking.
And we-- so from our perspective,
it is hard to understand, you know,
what the distinctions are when we,
you know, see someone testifying
about the need of teachers
across all disciplines.
Then, it turns out because they
are actually from media studies,
you know, we only get an
exemption for media studies.
And so, part of the reason
you've seen such an explosion is
that we have learned the lesson
that we have to bring sort
of a kindergarten teacher
and a first grade teacher
and a second grade teacher and
this is, you know, because--
because in the past, the Office
has rejected, for example,
when I bring in remix videos,
they've rejected the relevance
of the National History Day
people, who do make remixes,
but they make it in an
educational context.
So they don't count apparently for--
>> Regan Smith: Well, I do want to
push back a little bit on the idea
that you need to bring in
a kindergarten teacher,
a first grade teacher and
a second grade teacher.
I mean, what would
be the alternative?
Would it be that Professor
Decherney, you know,
shows and the Office has said this
is a great example of fair use
in cinema studies, and so
he testifies about his need
and an exemption is
granted and it is
for fair use for all
motion pictures.
Where would the line be drawn?
>> Rebecca Tushnet: So motion
pictures in educational context,
absolutely, because
what he testifies
about is pedagogical practice.
And certainly, the people that we
have-- so Renee Hobbs, for example,
she's actually not just a media
educator, she actually works
in the pedagogy of education.
And so, that's the kind of thing
where the evidence in front
of you actually supports the
generalization being offered
because it's about how pedagogy
works, not about how media studies
in particular works or language
studies or film studies.
And we think that a similar level of
generality, similar to what you see
in fair use cases, right.
So people in fair use cases,
they list education,
criticism, commentary.
They don't say media studies
and there's a reason for that.
And I think that that kind of change
could really help decrease the
burden on you as well as
align it, as Raza was saying,
more with the needs-- the statute.
>> Regan Smith: Mr. Turnbull?
>> Bruce H. Turnbull: Well,
far be it from me to advocate
for exemptions, but I really think
that the focus on K through 12
or particular types of higher
education has enabled the Office
to make recommendations
for exemptions,
whereas a much broader category,
as had been in the early rounds,
resulted in no exemption
recommendation and that if you--
if you, again, if you start out with
the proposition that the default is
that the prohibition on
circumvention shall apply,
which is what the statute and
the legislative history tell you,
unless there is a particular
body of evidence saying
that a particular use
is being frustrated
by the particular technology
involved,
then if you have a broader
category, you're much more likely
to find that, no, in
the broader category,
there is not the frustration
of the use.
Whereas if in a narrower category--
I mean, Professor Decherney
did a really superb job in 2006
of explaining why it was that
he needed what he needed.
And I think that the evidence that's
been presented in other cases--
while I, again, with Mr. Williams,
I'm not always happy
with the result.
I think there has been a
reasonable outcome based
on what's been presented.
And if there are ways to make
that a little easier for some
of the proponents, I'm
not opposed to that.
But I think that the-- the way
the categories are defined has
in fact enabled the granting
of certain exemptions
that in a broader category
would not have been granted.
>> Regan Smith: Mr. Williams?
>> Matt Williams: Thank you.
Yeah, I agree with Bruce.
I think your question was if the
approach to class of works changed,
would that end up resulting
in fewer exemptions.
And I think if you followed
the approach as you have
and only altered that portion that
it would, because you, as you said,
need to decide that the use
is likely non-infringing.
I actually think you have
to go farther than that.
You have to actually decide
that it is non-infringing
because the statute says
likely adverse impact.
It doesn't say likely
non-infringing use.
But that's a disagreement I have.
But in order for you to
make that conclusion even
that it's likely non-infringing use,
you have to start engaging in some
of the line drawing that
is being criticized.
So you've done things like focus
on use of short portions of a works
for criticism and commentary
in noncommercial sectors.
Those things help you
get to the conclusion
that what the proponents
want to do is a lawful use.
And you have to get
to that conclusion before
you can grant the exemption.
You also have to get
to the conclusion
that there are not reasonable
alternatives available.
So you have to draw the lines
that were being criticized
between different formats because
just because someone who's engaged
in a certain activity wants
to use DVD-quality footage,
that doesn't mean that they have
to have Blu-Ray quality footage.
And so, the line drawing that you've
engaged in I think has allowed you
to craft exemptions that comply
with the statutory requirements
and that also give the proponents
a lot of what they're asking for.
So I would be careful playing
around with doing away with some
of this-- this line drawing.
A couple of very quick responses.
On the burden of proof
issue, I think, you know,
this was heavily debated in the
2000 rulemaking and then all
over again in the 2003 rulemaking.
There were a lot of disagreements
at that time between NTIA
and the Office as to
how to read the statute.
One thing they both agreed on
though was that the burden is
on the proponents and
that that's a requirement
in the legislative history.
And Federal Register
65, page 64558 goes
through the office's initial
reasoning as to why the burden needs
to be on the proponents, and I think
it's sound reasoning even to today,
citing case law and other
sources that basically say
that when you're dealing with
an exception to a general rule,
the burden is on the proponent of
the exception to make its case.
So I'd urge you to go back to that.
I think I'll end there.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Ms. Cox?
>> Krista L. Cox: So I agree
with a lot of what Raza
and Professor Tushnet said, that
I think-- and Professor Decherney,
that defining based on uses
really does make a lot of sense,
that it does put it
in line with fair use.
And, I think that distinguishing
between the different educational
uses, between K through 12 or,
you know, media studies
or other disciplines
in college really doesn't
make a lot of sense
because we are talking
about pedagogy.
We're talking about
educating students.
And, I would just say
that trying to draw all
of those distinctions
actually makes the actual text
of the exemptions not as
usable, not as friendly.
For example, in the most
recent rulemaking process,
the exemption for film
clubs was 1055 words long.
The 2006 exemption
was 44 words long.
A 44-word exemption is a lot easier
for the average teacher or person,
user to understand versus having
to really parse through the statute
and really understand what is
allowed or what's not allowed.
So I think if you went back to
looking at the uses instead of,
you know, the classes of users, I
think that it would make it easier
for us to understand
it and you wouldn't go
through such a long
and drawn out process.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Thank you.
Ms. Greene?
>> Robyn Greene: Thank you.
I just wanted to respond.
This is a little bit off-topic
from your question directly,
but to what Mr. Williams was saying
about the proper interpretation
of whether or not something
is infringing.
And it is our position that the
Copyright Office should be uniformly
applying a standard that
they merely have to find
that a proposed exemption
is likely non-infringing.
We think that this emanates
directly from the statute,
as the Cyberlaw Clinic at Harvard
stated as well in its comments.
Our view is certainly
in line with that.
And we would also urge a narrow
interpretation of the question
as to whether the proponent
of the exemption experiences adverse
effects as a result of the TPM.
We think that both of these would
be in keeping with the intent
of the statute and would allow
for a better implementation
of the rulemaking process.
>> Regan Smith: Professor Decherney?
>> Peter Decherney: Just to
quickly set the record straight,
when I'm criticized by Professor
Tushnet and praised by Mr. Turnbull.
In 2006, we did actually apply for
an exemption for media professors.
Immediately, we were criticized by
everyone who said, what about us,
we also need an exemption.
And as a result, had evidence from
people across the academy and lots
of stories from people in many
different fields, but also support
from many different
professional organizations,
including the American Association
of University Professors,
the largest organization
of academics.
And so, that-- who
are all represented
by me normally during the
rulemakings, not today,
although they have
submitted comments actually.
So it is a broad exemption.
I just-- a one quick point
about what Mr. Williams was
calling the line drawing
and I think this relates to
Ms. Cox's comments as well.
But we are often talking about these
distinctions between DVD and Blu-Ray
and it's not about non-infringing
uses versus non-- non-infringing--
the infringing uses, but about
the level of need, of quality,
when and what constitutes something
that's useful for education
or for archiving purposes.
And it's not clear exactly
what the standard is there.
I mean, I don't know, if you
want to be convinced by us
that it is something we need.
But I think some kind of
clearer understanding of what
that bar is would be terrific.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
So the next area I'd like to
tee up is the burden of proof,
which some have already
sort of spoken about.
Mr. Williams has quoted what
the Office said in the statute.
It says the librarian
needs to make a finding
of something that's
specifically going
to happen in the next three years.
So, I think there's two
sides to this question.
First is the Office has said
that the burden of proof is
on the proponent and
we've also heard
that it's taking legal
clinics hundreds of hours.
So there's both a substantive and a
procedural angle to this question.
Should the Office institute reforms
that give people less
opportunities to submit evidence?
Would that hurt the ability for
proponents to obtain an exemption
or are there specific
reforms we should consider?
Mr. Mohr?
>> Chris Mohr: I think there
are certain things-- I'm sorry.
I think there are certain things you
might be able to do through concepts
of administrative notice that
would streamline the proceeding.
I think it's totally reasonable for
someone who has proven an exemption
to provide information in
abbreviated form, for example,
that they have used the exemption.
It would certainly be helpful
to say, yes, we've used this,
and here's a couple of
brief examples of the kind
of thing that we've done.
I'm not talking about a, you know,
300 page, thousand-footnote filing,
this is what I did with my summer
vacation, that kind of thing.
And provided that's all that's being
sought is the exact same exemption
from the year before,
that should be enough,
unless somebody else comes forward
and says, no, things have changed,
the exemption is being abused,
there is some other evidence that,
you know, there is someone-- there
was some flaw in the case beforehand
that warrants a revisiting of
this or something, you know,
a rebuttal basically, a
rebuttal of that evidence.
But the burden-- you're right.
The burden has to be
on the proponent first.
But after that, I think you as an
administrative agency as opposed
to a court have more flexibility
in how you handle the rulemaking
from that point as it goes forward.
>> Kevin Amer: Just to sort of
focus a little bit on this question
of what we as the Office can do
versus what might require
statutory change
on this question of
the burden of proof.
We have said that the proper
showing is a preponderance
of the evidence standard,
which requires a more
likely than not showing.
Is there agreement that that is the
proper sort of baseline framework
that we should be applying
or do people have a view
that we have some latitude
in that area?
Mr. Panjwani?
>> Raza Panjwani: I
don't think we take--
or at least speaking for
public knowledge or take issue
with the idea of a
preponderance of evidence standard
for meeting the burden
of proof as a proponent.
I think, however, where our
disagreement enters in is what
that mean with respect
to each of the elements.
What is showing non-infringing use
by a preponderance of the evidence
and what are the adverse effects
that the statute contemplated
that proponents would be
required to demonstrate in order
to meet a preponderance
of evidence standard?
>> Regan Smith: Professor Tushnet?
>> Rebecca Tushnet:
So I was just going
to say exactly what-- exactly that.
Don't-- we should definitely
not change the process
to give us less opportunity
to make our case.
You know, I think there would
be serious due process problems
with that, among other things.
But the real-- the reason these
submissions are 150 pages long is
because of this question,
burden of proof
and the preponderance
of evidence as to what.
And again, I'd direct you
to the Cyberlaw Clinic.
You know, the burden of proof
should be about non-infringing use,
adverse effects, not the
nine different things
that the Copyright Office
has come up with over time,
which do contribute to the
fact that we feel like we have
to meet the burden on
other considerations
that may be added into
the process later.
And I think adhering
to the statutory text could
really solve a lot of that.
Actually, could I actually
respond to something earlier?
Because I feel like I
don't want to let it go.
In terms of the question of 1201
interfering with the development
of case law, so we heard that
that didn't really happen.
Let me offer you two pieces of
evidence that it does, first of all,
as my own experience and
that of the OTW as a whole.
So we counseled remixers
before the exemption happened.
Remixers often-- well, not often,
but occasionally would
receive DMCA notices.
We'd talk to them about whether
they wanted to counter-notice.
And we always had to ask
them before the exemption,
how was this footage made?
And because nobody knows about the
DMCA, almost all of them made it
by DVD ripping because that's what
gives you the most effective source.
And nobody that I counseled
thought, oh yeah, I should go ahead
and make my fair use argument
even though I would be willing
to go ahead and do that, because
I'm definitely going to lose, right?
You have to tell them, look,
if you made it the wrong
way, you're going to lose.
It doesn't matter that you
have a good fair use case.
>> Regan Smith: So in
that example, I mean,
what is-- what is the alternative?
It seems like it may be statutory
reform, since the statute requires--
>> Rebecca Tushnet: No--
>> Regan Smith: -- the
non-infringing uses exist as opposed
to proponent case law, right?
I mean, the earlier panel, we talked
about Congress making the decision
to protect access to
copyrighted works separately.
>> Rebecca Tushnet: Well, I'm sorry.
Maybe I wasn't clear.
Before we succeeded the first
time in getting the exemption,
that's how I had to counsel people.
Now, I can counsel
people, saying go ahead.
I don't have to ask them
how the footage was created.
Go ahead. Do your counter-notice and
if they sue, we'll represent you.
And I tell you, no
counter-notice that I've worked
with has ever proceeded to a case
because remixers get takedowns
that are unjustified, something that
we have talked about in other fora.
But at the very least, the
copyright owners have decided not
to pursue claims when we thought
there was a very strong fair use
case and we were willing
to make that,
which we couldn't do
before we had our exemption.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
So it sounds like the
exemption in this case
and process was working and--
>> Rebecca Tushnet: Well,
so in terms-- right.
Now we are ready to make-- right?
We're ready to litigate some of
the issues that before we existed.
There was really nobody who
would represent a non-commercial,
you know, most non-commercial
cases don't end up in court
because the defendant
can't find a lawyer, right?
We're now there to do that.
And you know, we're
waiting for the right case,
which we just couldn't do before.
And then, the other thing I
would mention is the dicta
in the Corley case which
has already come up opining
on stuff that's not before it, about
the question of quality, like what--
you know, does fair use
require a particular quality?
So that's something that
has been a real problem.
It's explicitly disavowed by
subsequent Second Circuit precedent.
But it still haunting us, as you can
see by the fact that it's brought
up 16 years later about whether
you actually do have an entitlement
to the right quality for,
you know, your fair use.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Mr. Williams, I think, if you wanted
to respond to the initial question
about burden of proof and
preponderance of evidence?
>> Matt Williams: Yes.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
>> Matt Williams: On preponderance
of the evidence, I think I saw a lot
of confusion in the comments
on what the standard means.
And as you said, it means
more likely than not,
which is not a terribly
difficult standard.
It's the standard you're
usually dealing with at trial.
So if you show 51% and
the other side's got 49,
that's a close call,
but you still win.
So a lot of the comments seem
to think it meant something
quite different
and I think you could clear
that up just by clarifying.
You've repeatedly done that
in your NOIs every cycle.
You've explained what it means.
But there seems to
still be come confusion.
And I think that might be
because people get troubled
by the substantial
adverse impact standard,
which is the burden they
have to meet is to show
that substantial adverse impact by
a preponderance of the evidence.
And you've also gone out of your
way in every cycle to explain
that substantial is not
something that requires proof
that something absolutely
terrible has happened to you.
It's-- It comes out of the
legislative history that calls
for distinct, verifiable
and measurable impacts
or that says mere inconvenience
is not enough.
All of those things were worked
through in the 2000 cycle.
And then, in 2003,
the Office reiterated
that it's not imposing any
burden that isn't already
in the legislative history
by saying substantial.
It's just saying don't come
to us with a hypothetical.
Don't come to us
with a philosophical
objection with the law.
Tell us about a real-world issue
and we'll consider
granting the exemption.
So I think the burden
has been handled properly
and it's not something
that should be changed.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
I think we'll go to Ms. Greene next.
But one question, does anyone
want to specifically comment,
thinking ahead on the Breaking
Down Barriers to Innovation Act,
which would change statutorily
and impose a totality
of the circumstances test?
So, Ms. Greene?
>> Robyn Greene: So I just wanted
to respond to Mr. Williams' citation
to the Manager's Report and
dependence on that as sort
of the best source of
legislative history.
I would call into question whether
or not those are actually
appropriate standards.
I mean, when you look at
the actual statutory text,
it does not impose any kind of
substantial burden requirement.
It says merely, as Mr.
Williams was citing earlier,
that the person be adversely--
sorry, that someone is likely to be
in the succeeding three-year
period adversely affected
by virtue of the TPM.
And so, I do think the appropriate
standard for inquiry is whether
or not someone's proposed
use is likely non-infringing,
which would also be in
keeping with the preponderance
of the evidence standard,
right, more likely than not.
And then, also, seek to
determine just whether
or not quite simply something does
impose an adverse effect as a result
of the TPM, not imposing some
type of heightened standard
as to the level of
that adverse effect.
It's not clear in the statutory
language or in the majority
of the legislative history,
as opposed to the sort
of minority report by a
single member of Congress
that there was contemplated any kind
of like a substantial
adverse impact.
It seems more likely in fact that
the intent was to determine whether
or not there is any adverse
impact, and then to err on the side
of granting the exemption,
as this was, of course,
meant to be a failsafe
for people whose fair uses
and other non-infringing uses
would otherwise be made impossible
as a result of 1201.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Thank you.
And I know a lot of the
written comments do expose a lot
of viewpoints on the legislative
history too and, obviously,
we're taking those into account.
And so, on totality of the
circumstances test, Mr. Panjwani,
if you'd like to respond?
>> Raza Panjwani: Sure.
The Breaking Down Barriers
to Innovation Act--
as best as I can recall it
offers a number of amendments
by explicitly placing
into the statutory factors
for granting exemptions,
a lot of the things
that we've talked about here.
It is still our position
at Public Knowledge
that the statute can be
interpreted to allow for many
of those things, if not all of them.
We can disagree on some of that.
To focus again on the example
you asked for about development
of case law, one of the exemptions
that we originally asked for
and this is a bit of-- sort of a
Sisyphean gag between ourselves
at Public Knowledge and Mr.
Turnbull and Mr. Williams,
is the DVD space-shifting exemption,
which we apply for
every three years.
I will note that while the Copyright
Office disagrees with our analysis
of the case law as to whether
that is a non-infringing activity,
NTIA in its report, looking
at the same case law,
comes to a differing conclusion.
They also reach, I believe,
a disagreeing opinion
with the Copyright Office
as to whether narrative filmmakers
are more likely than not to be able
to make fair uses of video clips.
And I think this highlights the
problem that I talked about earlier
of a bad jurisdiction sort of thing
that we have two competent agencies
reaching opposite interpretations
of the copyright law and that the
appropriate authority to settle
that dispute is a federal court.
And the only way that gets to a
court is if there is an exemption
that allows us to settle the
copyright issue because--
>> Regan Smith: So--
>> Raza Panjwani: Sorry.
Go ahead.
>> Regan Smith: Can I ask
how would you reform that?
Would it be statutory reform
and the statute contemplates the
librarian makes a determination
based on the recommendation
of the Register of Copyrights
who in turn consults with NTIA and
so takes all that into account and,
you know, puts into a final
rule granting of exemptions?
Would you-- what would
the reform be for that?
Would you tip the scales
in the case of disagreement
or what would you propose?
>> Raza Panjwani: I think the
appropriate interpretation is
that a preponderance of
evidence standard applied
to the non-infringement element is
that barring affirmative case
law saying that that activity is
in fact infringing, that the
tie goes to determination
of non-infringing as
to that element.
Because if the Copyright
Office is wrong,
rights holders have the ability to
bring a case in court and settle
that question and thus
close off that exemption
by finding of infringement.
>> Regan Smith: So I
mean, just to be clear,
it sounds like you're
disagreeing with the outcome
but perhaps not the process.
Is that right or?
>> Raza Panjwani: In this particular
example, I'm disagreeing with both.
I think that if the process
had worked appropriately,
that the fact that
there's a disagreement
between the two agencies
and the fact
that there was no affirmative
precedent
that that activity was
infringing should have resulted
in that element coming out
in favor of an exemption.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Mohr?
>> Chris Mohr: A couple of things.
The first thing is that-- sorry.
The first thing is that and I think
it goes, you know, it does go kind
of to this proof question, is-- and
the legislative history is that,
my friend to my right
must have misspoken
because the statute says nothing
about being affected by TPMs.
That's what it said in
the Commerce Committee.
It was changed when it
went to the House floor.
And now, it says prohibition.
And in conjunction with
that, that's when--
that was the circumstances
surrounding the issuance
of the Manager's Report.
Now, it's interesting
that in its submission,
that textual change was something
that was I don't think mentioned
in the Harvard submission.
And that is a-- in
my mind, at least,
was a fairly significant omission.
The-- WITH respect to the--
with respect to the influence
of the Manager's Report itself,
I would refer you to Sutherland
on statutory construction, 4814,
which has a nice summary and case
law and so forth, of the statements
by the managing committee
member and the deference
that is ordinarily applied.
Obviously, it's statutory
construction, so that's not,
you know, it's not absolute rules.
But the general rule that, in my
mind, the Office properly applied
in this case is contained there
and you may find it useful.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Turnbull?
>> Bruce H. Turnbull:
A couple of things.
First, I'm also puzzled on the
statutory background because--
and recognizing that there
were changes made later on.
And it was just mentioned, the
core of sort of what are the--
what are the-- what are
supposed to be the elements
of the regulatory proceeding came
out of the Commerce Committee.
And the Commerce Committee--
I think what Mr. Williams
quoted before was straight
from the Commerce Committee report,
not the statement of managers.
And so, I think the, you
know, the distinct, verifiable
and measurable impacts that the
repeated emphasis in that report
on the need for evidence is--
that was the Committee
that created the process.
Now, the process was
changed a bit and moved
from the Commerce Department
to the librarian
and the Copyright Office
and that sort of thing.
And in that regard, it seems to
me that Congress actually spoke
and said that the Commerce
Department role was to be advisory
and the librarian, upon the
recommendation of the Register
of Copyrights, was to be definitive.
And so, the fact that
NTIA may disagree
about something is not dispositive
of anything other than the fact
that they're an advisor,
not the decision-maker.
And on the-- so yeah, I think that
was the point I wanted to make.
Thanks.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Just to-- to Ms. Cox.
>> Krista L. Cox: So I just
want to talk a little bit
about the preponderance of the
evidence and what that means
because in the-- in past
rulemaking cycles, when the groups
that represented blind
organizations, blind individuals
who wanted an exemption,
they went for it--
I think this was the 2006
rulemaking cycle and said, you know,
these are the number of
books that we have looked at
and that we are unable to access
via text-to-speech or, you know,
transforming into some
accessible format.
And the joint reply comments from
rights holders like AAP, MPAA, RIAA,
SIIA and others, Authors Guild,
you know, they basically said
that the submissions did
not give any indication
that the exemption had already
been used and that it was difficult
to evaluate in the absence of
any evidence about the extent
to which the exemption
had made things better.
And I think that some
of the difficulty
around bringing forward
this evidence and meeting
that evidence burden
is the confusion
on what evidence is needed.
Like do you need to show that the--
that by preponderance
of the evidence
that the past exemption
has made things better,
because it's extremely
difficult to get that evidence
in certain circumstances
such as for the blind.
I think it should be enough to show
that there are a significant number
of literary works out there,
that there are literary works
that blind people wanted
to be able to access
and they were unable to do so.
So that touches both on what
the evidence standard should be
but also just going back to this
process that it's extremely long
and hard to get all
of the evidence needed
to put these submissions forward.
>> Regan Smith: And in
the example that you gave
for assistive technology
for the blind, I mean,
this might be something where if you
had a separate or a different track
for renewals, that might
resolve that, correct?
>> Krista L. Cox: Absolutely,
and the Breaking Down Barriers
to Innovation Act would, you know,
grant renewal of these previously
granted exemptions without--
unless there's some showing that
things have changed and I think
that makes a lot of sense and I know
will be discussed in the next panel.
So I'm going to try to
stay away from that.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
I'm going to let Mr. Williams
get a chance to respond
to the responses to him, so.
>> Matt Williams: Thank you.
I'm not going to respond
on everything, just Bruce
and Chris are right
that I quoted both
from the Commerce Committee Report
and from the Manager's Report.
And I think the Manager's
Report is completely valid
legislative history.
But even if you don't like that
report because it disagrees
with your position, there are other
reports that take the same position
as the Manager's Report and
the Office has noted that.
On this issue of likely
non-infringing, it's two issues.
One, I've already mentioned, which
I think the modifier in the statute,
it says likely to be
in the succeeding three-year
period adversely affected.
And then, it doesn't
again say in their ability
to make likely non-infringing uses.
It says in their ability to
make non-infringing uses.
And, you know, a judge doesn't tell
you this is likely what the law is.
The judge says this
is what the law is.
And I think that's the standard
that was called for here.
The Office has taken
a different approach.
But I don't think there's anything
for the proponents to criticize
because the Office is
already interpreting it
to say likely non-infringing.
To take it a whole step further and
say that the copyright owner needs
to come in and show that there
is an adverse judicial precedent
against their position
in order to succeed
in the rulemaking just
completely upends copyright law
because the default in section 106
is that if you're making a copy,
if you're adapting
a work, et cetera,
you're committing an
act of infringement.
You then have an affirmative burden
to prove a defense such as fair use
or one of the other exceptions.
And so, I don't see why the standard
would differ in this context.
That's all I needed to say.
Thanks.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Thank you.
I think we'll call on Professor
Tushnet, then Professor Decherney,
and then move on to a new question.
>> Rebecca Tushnet: So, thanks.
I just want to make a comparison to
the statutory interpretation issue.
Consider copyright
preemption in section 301.
So there, the statute was
changed after the report came out.
And courts have again and
again and again agreed
that the legislation is not helpful
because of the material
way the statute was changed
between the time the report
came out and its enactment.
And it's actually exactly
the same here.
When you say that Commerce became an
advisor and not the decision-maker,
it's not a trivial change.
It's actually a complete
change in not only, you know,
what branch of the government is
making the law, but also, you know,
the fundamental underlying
orientation of the decision-maker
and what it's trained in doing.
So I do not think that
reports about the statute
that isn't the statute we have
are actually helpful either way.
I think we end up with
the text of the statute.
And then, also just in terms
of what Mr. Williams just said
about upending copyright law,
I feel like we spent the last
sessions saying, "But wait,
you know, this isn't
about copyright law.
This is about access."
So if in fact the question is,
you know, will making access--
or not making access,
getting access allow me
to make a non-infringing use,
there's nothing upending about that
at all because at least
some of these accesses,
like the ones that my-- that
the people I represent have are
completely authorized.
You know, they bought the stuff.
They have, you know, they
can play it, you know.
And so, I don't think that this is
a question of upending copyright law
when the whole point is this
extends far beyond copyright law.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
>> Peter Decherney: Yeah.
Back to the preponderance
of the evidence standard,
this is about the question
about whether
or not is a measurable
preponderance of the evidence.
And I think we just want
to acknowledge that often,
what we're talking about are
things that are not measurable.
And so, we have anecdotes, but
we're talking about the degree
to which someone needs one media
versus another for
the same activity.
We might all agree that
making a remix video
or noncommercial video
is non-infringing,
but what is the level
of quality that's needed
for that non-infringing use.
I'm not always convinced that
it's something we can measure.
It's something we can argue for.
But I don't know that
it's ever measurable,
except with a lot of anecdotes.
>> Regan Smith: So a new
question I want to just take
in a different direction is
whether or not the triennial nature
of the rulemaking is something
that should be reexamined.
Is three years too long, too
short, any opinions on that,
is it working for everyone?
Mr. Panjwani?
>> Raza Panjwani: So
I'm going to go ahead
and have my cake and eat it too.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
>> Raza Panjwani: I will point
out that it's both too
short and too long.
In the case of advancing or dealing
with advancements in technologies
and new issues, as I mentioned
earlier, someone had brought
up to me the point that, you know,
consumer appliances aren't covered
and they discovered a
bug and they weren't sure
if they were legally
allowed to fix the bug
in this consumer appliance
based on the current rulemaking
and they'd have to wait for two
years to bring an exemption.
On the flipside of it, as a
proponent, having to come back--
and this again is going
to necessarily came
to the renewability
discussion in the next panel--
is that three years, you
end up having two years
to use your exemption, one year
to then deal with the cycle.
And I understand that that places
a similar burden on the Office,
that every-- one out of every three
years, a large number of staff have
to be devoted to this
one particular project.
And, you know, I recognize that.
But you know, how you square
that circle, I'll leave that up.
I would point out that it is
both too long and too short,
depending on the particular
problem you're trying to address.
So I don't think that there's
a one-size-fits-all necessarily
solution here of a particular term.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Williams?
>> Matt Williams: Thank you.
Yeah. I mean, it's a hard
number to come up with
if you're looking for
something perfect.
But if you're looking for something
that's good that makes sense,
I think three years
works pretty well.
A lot can change in
that period of time,
especially in this
current environment
of rapidly evolving technology.
But it also doesn't mean that
you're ending the proceeding
and starting it again the next day.
So I think three years
has worked pretty well.
And I wouldn't shorten it certainly
because it really would just mean
that we are all constantly
working on the proceeding
and there's no time for the
exemptions to take hold, settle in
and let us look at them and
see how they're working.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Mohr?
>> Chris Mohr: Just the
current statutory term is--
from our perspective, is fine.
And I would just resist the
premise that just simply
because a change has occurred,
that there is some need to tinker
with the premise of the statute,
because I think that's
lurking a lot behind the scenes
in a lot of these discussions.
There are lot of folks who don't
like the premise of that statute.
And that's fine.
We do and we think it's
worked exceptionally well.
There is a safety valve
that's this rulemaking
and we think the statutory
term is an appropriate way
to examine any problems
that might arise.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Ms. Cox?
>> Krista L. Cox: Once again,
I agree with Mr. Panjwani that,
you know, it can be both
too long and too short.
But I think a way to
kind of resolve this is
that when there is a need for--
you could have a shorter period
for a new exemption, for exemptions
that haven't been considered before
or haven't been granted before
so that you can keep up with
the advances of technology,
all of these new technologies
where you find
that you actually do
need a new exemption,
and it wasn't considered previously
or there wasn't enough evidence
to grant that exemption.
But if you had permanent
exemptions or you had this--
a streamlined process
where you didn't need to go
through these huge, you know, de
novo proceedings every three years
for educational uses,
for assistive technology,
for persons with visual impairments.
I think that shortening that period
for new exemptions would
make a lot of sense.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Professor Decherney?
>> Peter Decherney: Yeah.
So that really sounds
really appealing--
>> Regan Smith: Can you
turn on your microphone?
>> Peter Decherney: That sounds
really appealing if there's--
I don't know what it would look like
but if there's a different timeframe
for new exemptions versus renewals.
I just know towards the
end of the last rulemaking,
bibliographic scholars came
to me with a great problem.
And I said, you know, I'm
sorry, it's actually four years
until we can-- till
that can be addressed.
But it's an important one.
And in an educational context,
that can be a long time.
You know, it's the entire
education of a lawyer, right?
Three years, or at least
the school education.
Yeah, so if I can just suggest
something that's really,
really practical, but I think
would be helpful, is to recognize
that it's law school
clinics which do a lot
of the representation
for the proponents.
And if there were just ways of
thinking about that calendar,
the academic calendar in the
context of the rulemaking,
I think would really help.
You know, many, many
times I've had--
I work with the American
University Law Clinic.
But then, the questions we get
after the hearing or some other part
of it falls outside of
the academic calendar,
and that complicates things.
>> Regan Smith: Yeah.
And that actually was the
next line of questioning.
I wanted to bring up and open it
to everyone what are, you know,
sort of if we stay
within this sandbox,
we've obviously talked about, you
know, ways to change the sandbox.
If we stay within the sandbox, what
are reforms that the Office can do
to make the process work better?
Believe it or not, we tried to be
cognizant of the academic calendar.
But academies are not
always on the same schedule.
But so how would it work
for law clinics' schedules?
What about issuing
post-hearing letters?
Are the hearings themselves
that we conduct helpful?
Should there be in more cities?
Should it be handled differently
because it creates travel
expenses, et cetera?
So if you-- if you I
think originally, we--
last rulemaking, we
started it in July was
when the petitions were due.
And then-- is that right?
And then-- or at least if you
wanted to suggest a timing
that you think would work
with the academic calendar,
we would be grateful.
>> Peter Decherney:
Sorry, just anecdotally?
So if this were one week earlier,
the AU students would
have been in session.
But now they're not.
They're still helping with--
>> Regan Smith: Right.
Mr. Williams?
>> Matt Williams: Sure.
So I think there were
kind of two parts to that.
First, on the academic calendar,
I think it would be great
if the hearings could take place
when the students who worked so hard
on this hearing could
appear and make their case.
I know we've heard a good bit today
about how burdensome the process is
and I don't mean to
make light of the amount
of work that goes into it.
But I think it's fantastic
that a lot
of really great young
copyright lawyers are getting
to sink their teeth into this during
law school and if they got to show
up and do some oral advocacy at
the hearing that would be great.
>> Regan Smith: And would that be
spring or would that be summer?
I mean, even more specific--
practically, what does that mean?
>> Matt Williams: Sure.
I think the problem now and I'm not
currently teaching, although I have
in the past, is that
the hearings come just
after the students have left for
the year I think is the problem.
But I'll let the professors
speak to that.
The other issue that I think you
raised is, are there any other ways
to improve either the
hearings or the process
through post-hearing letters.
And I mentioned earlier we'd love to
see some kind of drafting approaches
at the end of the process.
And in the past, when I've
raised that, I've been told
that there's just no time.
And I do understand
that's a real concern.
But I think, given there
is already a period
for post-hearing letters
built into the process,
that if the drafting issues
were just presented to hearing,
people who appeared at the hearing,
it could fit into that window,
we could have a chance to
give you some feedback.
And I think that would
be really helpful.
And then, on the hearings, I think
they are often very, very helpful
and I think they really
run quite well.
One issue that we do run into is,
as we've said in our comments,
if we're preparing a fact witness
to come in and give testimony
on one issue but it relates
to, you know, every way really
that a movie studio uses access
controls on their content.
It's relevant across all
of the different proposals.
And so, last cycle, I think in
an admirable attempt to kind
of make sure that each proposal
was its own record, it was unclear
to us whether the Office could look
at the testimony from this proposal,
the hearing from that
proposal and then use it
when considering a
different proposal.
And I think that harm goes both
to our side and the other side
where the proponents
shouldn't necessarily have
to have the same person who
might be a small business owner
or whatever else show
up at multiple hearings.
So I think that would be a
helpful change across the board.
And then, just a little
bit of additional clarity
on exactly what type of evidence
can be presented for the first time
at a hearing, I've never quite
understood what the rule there is.
And it would be helpful
to clarify it I think
because sometimes during a hearing,
a witness will pull out their laptop
and say, well, I'm
looking at this new website
and isn't this a great
piece of information.
Other times, it's been a little
more like, well, if you didn't put
that in your comments, you
shouldn't be bringing it to us now.
I think both approaches
have ups and downs to them,
but it would be helpful to
know just which rule applies.
Thanks.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Professor Tushnet?
>> Rebecca Tushnet: So
I would again in terms
of how you can make this better
within the current sandbox,
again point you to the
Cyberlaw Clinic's suggestions,
which I think are quite detailed.
I also want to pick up on something
that came up in the first panel,
again talking about
how access is special.
So I think we have to
recognize that at this point,
access and rights controls
have been merged
by actors making strategic use
of 1201 so that the balance
that Congress did intend
in distinguishing access
from rights controls is now gone.
So remixers, for example,
and educators have
lawful, paid-for access.
What they need is the ability
to make their fair uses.
And the problem of the
merged access rights control,
which the Copyright Office
has repeatedly acknowledged
in these proceedings, you
actually could recognize
that as another factor.
So in the statute, it says other
factors that can be considered.
The deliberate merging of a rights
and access control should count
as another factor justifying
exemption.
And this would work both within the
traditional copyright categories
and outside them.
And I will point out
just here, you know,
Congress was envisioning
perhaps the celestial jukebox.
It was definitely not
envisioning the celestial fridge
or the celestial tractor.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Ms. Greene?
>> Robyn Greene: So one suggestion
that we have at OTI that might help
to make the rulemaking a little
bit more accessible would be
to create a process
whereby proponents
of exemptions would be able
to submit confidential
versions of their comments.
Oftentimes, particularly in the
context of security research
but also in the context of other
proponents seeking exemptions,
the proponents of the exemptions
will withhold certain critical
information because they
either fear legal liability,
they fear that they may be divulging
confidential business information
or, as is the case
with security research.
They fear that they may be divulging
information that could lead others
to identify and then
exploit vulnerabilities.
And so, by instituting a process
that would enable confidential
versions of comments
to be submitted, it would not only
make that process more accessible
and ensure that the Copyright
Office had all of the evidence
that they needed to make
a complete decision,
it would also institute a
process that's in fact in keeping
with other federal
agencies such as the FCC.
>> Regan Smith: And so,
would your proposal be
that confidential information
was entirely just delivered
to the Office or would, you know,
sometimes you'll see dual versions.
You'll have the public version
and the private version.
The public version may
describe in broad terms
but not disclose specifics, or how
would you envision that working?
>> Robyn Greene: Yeah.
I think that it's important for
there to be full public discussion
about sort of the broad parameters
of what some of this type
of confidential information
would touch upon.
But in order to really respect the
need to maintain certain information
as confidentiality, you would
have sort of that public version
that might be more general and
then the very specific confidential
version that could be submitted
directly to the Copyright Office.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Turnbull?
>> Bruce H. Turnbull: Yeah.
I wanted to comment
on a couple of points.
One, on this last one, on the
confidentiality submission,
I don't think we'd have
any problem with that.
We would want to urge the Office
to institute something that's done
in other agencies, an administrative
protective order or something
so that counsel and
potentially expert witnesses
for the other side could get
access to the confidential version.
But again, it's done in
recognition of the kinds
of concerns that were expressed.
So it doesn't sort of
expose it to the public.
But it does allow a response,
potentially confidential, as well
and there are a number
of precedents for that.
In my former life, I was a trade
lawyer and that happened regularly.
I did want to comment and if
you're going to get to this later,
I'll hold, but on the access point
that Professor Tushnet has
made a couple of times--
>> Regan Smith: Sure.
Go ahead.
>> Bruce H. Turnbull: A
couple of things about that.
First, the access that is granted,
for example, thinking of DVD
or in a Blu-Ray context, is to that
content in a particular context,
in a particular form,
in a particular format
and under the rules of the
system that are operated.
So although the content
is, if you will,
in the clear when it's
presented on the television set,
it is not in the clear in
a usable way in the system
that it is made available to.
So to say that, oh, we own it and
we have access to it is correct only
in the sense that it's
visually accessible.
And if you want to use
a camcorder or something
at the television screen, go for it.
But that doesn't--
[ Inaudible Remark ]
In the-- in a couple
of the prior panels,
that was used as an alternative
for the particular proposals
that were made and we represented
for the fair uses that were alleged.
But that's-- so that's one point.
So the access that's granted
is not-- is not generic.
It is particular.
The second point is that
in the statutory structure,
it's clear that Congress
contemplated this rulemaking to deal
with the uses of the content once--
in the context of the
access control.
I mean, that's why the rulemaking is
in the 1201(a) context
and not in 1201(b).
And so, the-- it seems to me that
the comments that were submitted
and you may hear more about in San
Francisco, but are raised, I think,
in Professor Tushnet's
comments, are--
mischaracterize the
nature of this proceeding.
This proceeding is about uses and
in the context of access control.
>> Regan Smith: Matt Williams?
>> Matt Williams: Thank
you, excuse me.
Thank you.
I agree completely with what Bruce
just said and I think it's wrong
to think that Congress
did not anticipate
that some TPMs would constitute both
access controls and copy controls.
And that's why we're here
for these proceedings.
But Congress did not
conclude that in every case,
that means that an
exemption should result.
Congress created the proceeding to
say that if there is an instance
where something is both an
access control and a use control
and a question is raised about
whether that inhibits a lawful use,
you go through the process
that's laid out in the statute.
You apply the factors.
You see if there are available
alternatives, et cetera.
And so, I think it's a bit of a
red herring to say that some merger
of access controls and use
controls has created problems
that were unanticipated.
I think they were anticipated
and that's what the
proceeding was created to do.
I also, like Bruce, would not have
a problem with the confidentiality.
I think we might also at times
benefit from filing some things
that we'd like to keep
out of the public eye.
But I would also urge that counsel
and maybe even certain
in-house counsel be allowed
to see the submissions.
Thank you.
>> Regan Smith: I will say
on the confidentiality,
that's something we're
certainly going to take a look
at in the study, especially since
it seems there's not an objection
to it.
But one thing I will say on behalf
of the Copyright Office is the
three-year rulemaking is a much
quicker pace than what some of
the other federal agencies do.
So we would want to avoid
recommending some change
that would cause a year of
fighting over the protective order.
>> Kevin Amer: I'd just like to
switch gears and raise another topic
that was the subject of a lot
of discussion in the comments.
And that's the statutory language
referring to such other factors
as the librarian may wish
to consider and the role
of non-copyright issues
as part of the rulemaking.
You know, we heard from
several commenters arguing
that the Copyright Office should
not properly consider these types
of issues and should leave
them to other agencies.
I think-- and we also had some
discussion about sort of the process
that that should involve,
whether it's within our authority
to affirmatively reach out
to other agencies or whether
under the statutory language we're
limited to consulting with NTIA.
So we'd appreciate
your views on sort of--
on the proper role of other
agencies and how we should go
about consulting with them on
issues within their jurisdiction.
Mr. Mohr?
>> Chris Mohr: Again, I
would go back to the concept
of the administrative
record and the breadth.
And I think that so
long as the things
on which you rely are
publicly disclosed,
I think you have a
fair amount of leeway
to amass information
from different sources.
But when you issue the rule, you
have to explain, yes, we saw this
and I think there probably has to be
some opportunity for public comment
on whatever was received.
But outside of that, I think that
was exactly the right approach was
to get information from
people who are experts
in particular subject matter that
the Copyright Office is not and,
you know, weigh their views,
even if you didn't completely
agree with them all the time.
>> Kevin Amer: Mr. Panjwani?
>> Raza Panjwani: It's been our
perspective that the other factors
that the librarian shall consider
factor is directed at the fact
that the proponents of an exemption
must prove something beyond
copyright itself, which
would be non-infringement,
in order to justify adverse effects
and that allows the librarian
to consider additional harms
experienced by proponents
in determining whether or not
an exemption is warranted.
In the last proceeding, we had of
course this interagency process
and it's consideration
of many other factors,
and it's been our perspective
that this is not really necessary
in the process of determining
whether an exemption is warranted.
This is a question of whether
copyright liability will attach
for certain activity.
And I don't think that, you know,
the technological protection
measures were considered
as a policy panacea for any
consideration under the sun,
whether that be product safety,
whether that be emissions,
whether that be medical devices.
I think there's often a conflation
of, you know, there's software
in here that implicates copyright.
Therefore, there's
something different now,
whereas a lot of these
devices have existed
and these concerns have existed
in the mechanical, non-software,
non-copyright-implicating way.
And law and policy has developed to
address those issues historically.
I think the car example is a
great one in which, you know,
there's concerns about, will
people could modify the software
on their car to allow them to
violate emissions standards.
People have been modifying
their cars for a century,
for as long as there have been cars.
And there have been
rules against that.
We have annual inspections
of cars to check
for emissions and things like that.
I think most areas of law have
already responded to the concerns
that we have brought up in a while.
I admire the Copyright Office
for thinking afar and realizing
that a lot of these things are
implicated by software now,
I don't think that this
proceeding is the appropriate venue
for addressing those concerns.
>> Regan Smith: So just to be
clear, taking the last rulemaking
as an example, we got a
petition that referenced--
I think this was sort of more
broadly to the internet of things
and it wasn't a lot of specifics
as to what they wanted to do,
but examples of I'd like
to hack the subway system,
I'd like to hack the nuclear power
grid, I'd like to hack automobiles.
I mean, should the Copyright
Office entirely ignore whether
or not there is a potential
public safety concern?
>> Raza Panjwani: I believe hackers
will hackers will hack those things
if they are malicious,
regardless of whether
or not there's a 1201
exemption for it.
>> Regan Smith: Sure.
Mr. Williams.
>> Matt Williams: Thanks.
I just quickly wanted to reiterate
what Allan Adler and Troy Dow said
in the last panel, that you have
to be really, really careful
about what constitutes a
core copyright concern.
That term, it would have to
be very carefully defined
to have any real benefit and
that there is this distinction,
as Professor Tushnet articulated,
between access controls
and copy controls.
And it's clear that Congress did
intend to protect access controls
for their own purpose
as access controls
to prevent unauthorized access
to works that are available
for subscription or
on-demand availability.
And one fact pattern that I
think demonstrates the importance
of that clearly is if you've
got a work that is available
and it's protected by an access
control and it's also protected
by a completely separate
copy control,
if you were to hack the
access control and gain copy--
and gain access to the copy,
you could watch the movie,
you could listen to the song,
you could read the book.
If the copy control
remained in place,
theoretically there's no nexus
to even a possible infringement.
And then, there would
be no violation.
I think Congress clearly
intended to prohibit that conduct.
So I'd just urge you
to be careful not
to undo the current statutory
construction if you start thinking
about ways to address so-called
not core copyright issues.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Thank you.
I think we have about
two more minutes.
So this will be sort of last call.
Professor Decherney?
>> Peter Decherney:
Really quick point.
The one that was made in
the last panel is that all
of these determinations
often will cut both ways.
When talking about public health,
we thought that hacking your
own devices was the issue
about public health during one
of the hearings last round.
And it turned out later we found
out right briefly afterward,
that actually it was the
companies that made the cars
that may have been
causing the public health
by not allowing hacking.
The same thing's true
about fair use.
We always think commerce is going
to favor the people
that want stronger TPMs.
But actually, there's a tremendous
amount of commerce which is enabled
by fair use and hacking T
forever, bypassing TPMs, yeah.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Turnbull?
>> Bruce H. Turnbull: Yeah,
I just wanted to say quickly
that as the representative of
two of the TPMs in wide use,
our interests-- and I think the
Copyright Office has taken those
into account under
this other factor--
have to do with the integrity
of our licensing system,
which is not necessarily copyright,
whether the particular thing
is a copyright infringement
or fair use or whatever it is.
It has to do with whether the
overall system can continue to exist
and the benefits from that
are to the copyright system
and the user-- using
public as a whole.
And so, as a more generic point, I'd
say that as you address the things
which are sometimes
called not core copyright,
you need to be really
careful because, again,
sort of eliminating other factors
would potentially eliminate things
that we think are important
for you to consider
in the context of expressive works.
>> Regan Smith: Thank you.
Mr. Panjwani?
>> Raza Panjwani: I just wanted to
return very quickly to something
that Ms. Greene and
Mr. Mohr were talking
about earlier regarding
the importance of the role
of legislative history has played
in the interpretation of how we go
about this rulemaking,
which is that--
well Mr. Mohr is correct that
there are certain approaches
for interpreting legislative history
more generally, in the specific case
of the House manager's
report for the DMCA,
there have been specific criticisms
as to how or what value it adds
to the interpretation of the law.
Her use of the word substantive
I think was a reference
to the substantive diminution
language from that report.
And in particular, I would just
point out that Professor Nimmer,
in his law review article
generally on the importance
of legislative history, taking
the DMCA as an important case,
specifically calls out the
Manager's Report as a report
that does actually offer very little
from his perspective in terms of how
to appropriately interpret
section 1201.
>> Regan Smith: OK.
Thank you.
I think with that, we're concluded.
We'll take a break for lunch and
come back at 1:30 for panel three.
Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.